welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
Christopher proteins enabling the next
generation of molecular diagnostics
presented by dr. James Bryan who is a
senior scientist at mammoth Biosciences
my name is Xavier Gutierrez and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation and if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem and this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits app located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to attain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Brian I will
now turn the presentation over to him
alright thank you for joining me I'm
really excited to be able to share with
you a little bit of what mammoth
Biosciences is doing with CRISPR
proteins to build the next generation of
molecular diagnostics today I will be
talking to you a little bit about our
company mammoth Biosciences then going
over the basics of CRISPR and how CRISPR
proteins function and then talking about
how you know CRISPR is not just what you
may have heard about as caste 9 and that
there's a wide diversity of these
proteins and then finally I'll be
sharing how we can harness CRISPR
proteins and CRISPR systems for
diagnostic applications so mammoth
Biosciences was founded in 2017 with the
mission to democratize Diagnostics it
was founded by PhDs from Stanford and UC
Berkeley and our one of our co-founders
is
Jennifer Doudna now Kris Pearn as you
may have heard is that has really
revolutionized biology Christopher is
not just Cassadine which is a been used
for genome editing but it has also found
applications in healthcare agriculture
and industry and is really moving these
large markets because of such a flexible
tool now Cassadine was originally came
out of the scene very recently in 2012
but it's applications are often limited
due to its size the fidelity and the
sequence requirements are around for
where it can edit sequences but recently
in 2016 at 2017 and 2018 new varieties
of chrisberg proteins have come out to
have unique properties that allow them
to be used in diagnostic applications
and mammoth is really leading the field
in applying these proteins CRISPR is
very powerful because it is filed the
can by ology search engine is able to be
targeted to specific genes of interest
and once it's targeted there you can do
interesting things with it such as edit
gene sequences knockout genes modulate
how genes are function and what mammoth
is really interested in is how we can
diagnose diseases and infections using
CRISPR proteins the real power of CRISPR
comes from its ability to be programmed
you have a guide RNA that pairs with the
cast protein and this protein RNA
complex is then able to find unique
sequences within a genome and then
perform functions such as what you may
have heard about in terms of gene
editing and but one of the more
interesting applications and which I'll
be sharing more about today is how we
can diagnose diseases and infections
using this technology now I'd like to
come and take a step back and think
about what talk about the basics of
CRISPR CRISPR is a system that's used in
bacteria for defending against invading
RNA DNA such as plasmids and viral
sequences so these can often take the
shape
systems besides Christopher can take the
shape of physical barriers that prevent
bacteriophages from interacting with
bacteria
you also have restriction modification
systems where you have enzymes and
modifications on host genomes that
prevents these restriction enzymes from
degrading the host
you also have Argonaut proteins which
there are proteins that are bound by
small rnas and directed to cleave and
remove those and then you also have the
these newly found CRISPR caste systems
which are very powerful and programmable
now CRISPR was initially kind of
characterized the first one in 1993 and
it wasn't until 2002 that the term
CRISPR was regularly used and CRISPR
stands for clustered regularly
interspaced short palindromic repeats as
these CRISPR systems were fleshed out it
was discovered in 2005 the protein cast
9 and then quickly in 2007 it was found
that CRISPR the real function of CRISPR
was to use as an adaptive immunity in
bacteria and then kind of from that and
identification it was realized that you
could program Casa 9 with these CRISPR
RNAs and with a combination of a tracer
RNA and then use that to program where
cast 9 will interact in the inside of it
genome now the components of a CRISPR
array are kind of four main pieces one
is you have cast effector protein a cast
one protein and a cast two protein this
is usually followed within the bacterial
genome by a series of repeat and spacer
sequences and these are the kind of core
components that are found in many
different types of CRISPR systems now in
order to function as a bacterial defense
mechanism one of the unique things about
CRISPR is able to acquire new sequences
and the function is an adaptive immune
system so what happens is that you have
these casts one and cast two proteins
that recognize what are called proto
spacers within
the genome of an invading bacteria or a
bacteriophage
or other invading nucleic acids these
cats won and cast two proteins
recognizes protospace tree sequence and
can integrate it into the genome of the
bacteria then the bacteria is able to
transcribe these a series of repeat and
spacer sequences in what is known as a
precursor guide RNA these are then
processed into mature guide RNAs and
loaded onto cache proteins which are
that kept waiting specifically the cast
effector proteins now these proteins
remain inactive until they encounter a
complementary nucleic acid such as when
that bacterias are exposed to another
violent threats and once this happens
the cast effector protein will initiate
cleavage of the target and clay ik acids
and these steps really incoming
encapsulate the three kind of core
features of any CRISPR cast system you
have adaptation which is recognizing
those foreign sequences and integrating
them into the bacterial genome
expressing those as mature guide RNAs
and loading them into proteins and then
finally the third piece is the
interference with a cast effector
proteins loaded as the guide RNA
recognizes the target sequence initiates
cleavage of a nucleic acid and once that
nucleic acid is cleaved other
endonucleases within the bacteria can
then come in and cleave that foreign DNA
now I'd like to talk a little bit as a
kind of a foundation of what how CRISPR
cast nine functions so similar to all
these other ones caste systems that I
have been kind of alluding to you have a
single guide RNA and the caste nine
protein these come together and the
purpose has nine protein is then
directed to a specific site within the
genome by its guide RNA this once a
protein has recognized that
complementary sites it will initiate
double strand cleave
and the way people have been able to use
this yet two leads for genetic
engineering and to modify sequences is
to rely on the imperfect repairment
mechanisms that try to repair this
double strand break which they can lead
to an insertion or deletion events or
sometimes can be coupled with smallest
recombination to add foreign sequences
into a gene out
now when cassadine is searching you
can't just searching for regions of the
genome you can't just choose any random
sequence cassadine requires there to be
what is known as a pam where protists
pose proto space their adjacent motif of
ngg and this is required to be located
next to the targeting sequence of any
region of interest and what's important
here is that this ng g or pam sequence
limits where you can place a caste nine
and so one of the things that people
have been very interested in is finding
new CRISPR systems that have different
pam motifs to open up new areas of
exploration so there are not an
exploration but new areas of new
procedures of the genome that can be
targeted so now I'd like to talk to you
a little bit about the diversity of
CRISPR caste systems there are many
different flavors of CRISPR proteins out
there you have both class one and class
two effector proteins class one the
effectors are actually divided into
multiple proteins and this is difficult
to use in you know in vitro or an in
vivo system because you have to come
recombine all these different proteins
and have them function together however
there's another group of CRISPR
effectors proteins called class two and
this includes class nine where all these
functions of the various caste one
proteins are actually combined into a
single large protein and so what has
really been exciting at mammoth is that
we have access to other varieties of
these class two or single casts effector
and the ones that I'll be talking to you
today about are called the cast 12 which
targets DNA cast 13 which targets RNA
and finally a very exciting new CRISPR
system called cask 14 which targets
single strand DNA to start off with I'll
be talking about cast 12 so cast 12 just
like cast 9 requires a guide RNA which
directs it to specific locations either
on single strand DNA or double strand
DNA and once it recognizes those sites
it'll initiate cleavage and one of the
nice things about cast 12 systems is
that they have a different Pam than past
9 so in this case instead of the ngg of
cast 9 they have this TTT B Pam where
the V is any nucleotide besides T one of
the really interesting things about cast
12 that is that when it recognizes a
targets it not only Cleaves its the
double strand DNA that it's targeted -
it actually initiates a an
indiscriminate cleavage of any non tart
any surrounding single strand DNA so
here is an example of experiments where
cast 9 is being incubated with on a lot
of targets with radioactively-labeled
single strand DNA and what you can see
is over time that single strand DNA the
dark band at the top is not to grade it
however doing the same experiments with
casts 12 you see that there's a rapid
degradation of that
radioactively-labeled single strand DNA
and you can see that where that dark
line is now shifting to the bottom of
the gel the other protein I'll be
talking to you about today's cast 13 so
cast 13 targets RNA so once the guide
RNA and cathodes can combine either
within a cell it'll then recognize RNA
and initiate cleavage and this can be
useful for decreasing the levels of RNA
within a cell which can then lead to
decreases in approach
so it's a way of modulating without
necessarily changing the genome the
expression of a particular gene or
protein within a within a cell similar
to a caste 12 though it was recently
discovered that when caste 13 is bound
to a target RNA it also releases this
indiscriminate cleavage of non target
RNA and so here on the right is an
example of a similar kind of experiments
the one I showed you with caste 12 where
if you incubate the caste 13 with no
target RNA and a radioactively-labeled
reporter you don't see cleavage of that
reporter however when the target is
present the caste 13 rapidly initiates
kind of this nonspecific or
indiscriminate cleavage of the reporter
molecule the third system I'll be
talking to you about today is called
caste 14-14 was recently discovered one
of our co-founders published a paper in
science of Latin late last year and
caste 13 unlike caste 12 in caste 13
requires three components for the
functional system one is a tracer RNA
the next is a guide RNA and finally the
caste 14 protein the these three
components combined then are able to
recognize single strand DNA and initiate
its cleavage one of the unique things
about caste 14 is that it's 50 percent
smaller than caste line or caste 12
which makes it much more accessible in
terms of putting it into virus see viral
sequences or eventually using it as a
genome editing tool one of the nice
things about caste 14 also is that it
doesn't require a Pam sequence so in
this gel I'm showing you the right we're
using four different CRNAs kind of
spaced at one nucleotide increments and
you can see that's no matter where we
put the C RNA as long as it's
complimentary to the target we get
degradation of that target RNA
now similar to caste 12 and caste 13
caste 14 also has this non discriminant
or indiscriminate cleavage activity and
so once it's about a little target it
not only Cleaves its target single
strand of your name but it'll initiate
cleavage of any single strand DNA around
it and here in the right is a [ __ ] of
a gel where a caste 30 caste 14 he's
bound to a single strand of DNA and it's
incubated with a radioactively-labeled
single strand DNA and you can see
cleavage of that cleavage of that single
strand DNA overtime even though it's not
actually being actively targeted by the
caps 14 complex all right so now that
I've kind of introduced these three
different proteins that mammoth uses I'd
like to now talk about how we can use
these for diagnostic applications so
current diagnostic technologies are kind
of come in two flavors
what is antibody based where you rely on
antibodies to rail identify a specific
protein and then you concentrate those
in order to produce a visible signal and
this could be something similar to a
lateral flow test the second kind of
major class of diagnostic technologies
is molecular diagnostics or just
generally are based upon PCR and here
you're taking primers that are specific
to a gene of interest and using thermal
cycling on a cue PCR machine to amplify
those and detect that sequence within a
sample however when we use CRISPR to do
Diagnostics is were slightly differently
so manases CRISPR technology is called
detector and what we can do is we can
take basically any sample from any
source do a crude sample prep and get
detection of a specific sequence and so
this kind of works in three specific
pieces three three kind of main parts
the first being having that sample and
then incubating that sample with
protein of interest and so whether
that's cast 12 cast 13 or cast 14 and
what happens is that when the protein
recognizes are the sequence of interest
we get cleavage of a reporter molecule
this could be a fluorescent reporter or
a colorimetric reporter and but it is
only activated when it's cleaved by this
CRISPR protein and basically through the
many rounds of cleavage by the CRISPR
protein we get a full activation of this
reporter and we can use this to
differentiate single nucleotide
polymorphisms we can do it for cancer
screening identify bacterial infections
or antibiotic resistance or identify
viral infections and really the beauty
of this system is that each test that we
do we can customize it with a unique
guide RNA alright so now I'm going to go
through a few examples of how we can use
our detective technology so first this
is an example of using cast thirteen
detector and we'll on patient derive
samples to identify a bacterial
infection so we start with an RNA sample
that's derived from a patient sample we
don't do any amplification whatsoever
and we just directly apply the cast
thirteen protein and its guide RNA and
we get cleavage of the reporter molecule
which we can then observe using a plate
reader or qPCR machine and you can see
on the right is the results of this
where we have two positive controls for
the two bacteria they were interrogating
here and the negative control and then
examples of four different patient
samples that were tested positive for
these two different bacteria all right
they're not in however in not all cases
do we have enough material in order to
do direct detection like we can with
cast thirteen how you know to overcome
this and increase the sensitivity of our
assay we can use isothermal
amplification coupled to our detector
technology so in this example we are
titrating a plasmid down and using an
isothermal method called our PA for a
quick 10 minute reaction and they
incubating that with cast 12 in order to
detect a signal and here you can see if
the purple bars are ones that have the
undergone this amplification and this
allows us to have a de molar sensitivity
whereas if we have no amplification will
fall off in the kind of nano molar peak
molar range one of the nice things about
cast falls detector is its ability to
differentiate between highly related
sequences so I'm going to show you an
example that comes from a screening for
HPV so HPV is a virus that affects 80
million Americans with 14 million
infections every year and it can lead to
cervical cancer and other types of
cancer however not all strains of HPV
are pretty equal some are more high risk
for cancer than others and support wheel
the screen for these however the
sequences between these HPV strains can
HPV strains can be quite similar and one
of the things we can do is we can use
cash twelve detector to differentiate
between these two strains here we're
showing HPV 16 and HPV 18 and the
position of guide RNAs for these two
different strains now to do this vast
thing we started with clinical samples
from human anal swabs these were quickly
treated with protein Esk underwent a
quick RPA reaction and then were
detected by a cast 12 and here what you
can see is that our detector technology
differentiating between HPV 16 and 18
and then you can see this has it's very
similar to the results you would get if
using a traditional PCR assay and really
the highlight here is that were able to
use very crude sample prep in an
isothermal method to get these kind of
results
alright in the next example I'd like to
share with you how we can use cast 14 to
differentiate
between single nucleotides no single
nucleotide polymorphisms so as you might
suspect when you're using caste 14 since
it can only detect single strand DNA we
must have an isothermal amplification
strategy that is able to be a couple
with then we were able to generate
single strand DNA in order to do this we
can again start with kind of a crew
patient sample such as spits do a quick
washes and lysis of that sample and then
using a phosphorylated primer to do the
isothermal amplification this generates
PCR our applicants that have on one
strand phosphorus phosphorus I related
sequence we can then combine cast 14 and
a t7 exonuclease which will
simultaneously remove the unmodified
strand of the product creating single
strand DNA and then allowing cast 14 to
recognize that single strand DNA and
cleave a reporter molecule if that
sequence of interest is presence and so
the example I'm going to show you today
involves looking at different sheathing
between a snip that is involved in for
the genetics of I color so in the brown
hi sequence is a egg whereas in the blue
eyes you have a G and so we can divide
design a CRNA that is specific for each
of these and differentiate this mutation
that occurs in her two so we can start
with spent to a quick detector reaction
using test 14 and differentiate between
blue and brown blue and brown eyes snips
now the genetics of eye colors are much
more complicated than just her too but
this is a great example of how we can
use past 14 to do kind of real-time
genotype so today I'm really sure with
you kind of the capabilities of Manas
crispers platform we not only can you
Cass 12 which has access to DNA both
single-stranded and double stranded but
we can use test 13 to inherit
interrogate are they and caste 14 - as
an alternative for DNA and all of these
three proteins on like Cassadine have
this indiscriminate cleavage property
and lower Pam requirements which make
them much more accessible for a variety
of applications particularly in
Diagnostics now mammoths vision is to
combine the kind of advantages of rapid
at-home testing such as lateral flow
with kind of the high sensitivity of
molecular diagnostics that are not
accessible because they require
expensive lab equipments but really you
know by coming to by coupling these two
pieces and the rapid format with that
and the high sensitivity mammoth wants
to leverage this detector technology you
can bridge the gap that exists in
traditional methods bringing the power
of molecular diagnostics into a readily
accessible format and I want to thank
you for joining me today and talking
about CRISPR CRISPR technologies now
even beyond caste 9 and really going
into mammoths
kind of makes ever-expanding CRISPR
platform for diagnostics thank you well
thank you dr. Alan for the informative
presentation I would also like to thank
elaborate for making today's educational
webcast possible and as a final reminder
dr. Brennan will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
it's all for now thank you for joining
us we'll see you next time
goodbye